استمرار وانقاذي عالقنا بتركيا بعد عشره
ايام على وقوع الزلزال اجتماع عاجل بشان
ماربورج الذي يقتل 90% من المصابين به
روسيا تسخر من السخافات الامريكيه حول
الاجسام المجهوله هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
في مفاجاه غير متوقعه افادت وسائل الاعلام
التركيه بانقاذ سيده اربعينيه من تحت
الانقاض في كرما المرعش بعد مرور 222 ساعه
على وقوع الزلزال المدمر لقطات تلفزيونيه
اظهرت عمال الانقاذ ينقلون المراه واسمها
مليكه امامو على نقاله الى سياره الاسعاف
بعدما حوصرت تحت انقاض منزلها لنحو عشره
ايام واستمرار جهود فرق الانقاذ في عثور
العثور على ناجين رغم تلاشى الامان
بالعثور على احياء فيما تحدثت معلومات عن
انقاذ سيده وطفليها من تحت انقاذ منزلهم
في انطاكيا بعد
228 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال
نبقى مع اخبار الزلزال اذا كشف مختصون
سببا وراء استخدام فرق الانقاذ بطانيات
مصنوعه من الالومنيوم لتغطيه اجسام
الناجين من تحت الانقاض مختصون في مجال
الانقاذ قالوا ان السبب في استعمال هذه
البطانيات بطانيه الالومنيوم سواء ذات
الالوان الذهبيه او الفضيه هذا لكونها
تساعد على تدفئه الجسم في الاجواء البارده
بشكل سريع او تعديل حرارته في الاماكن ذات
الحراره المرتفعه مشرين الى انها خفيفه
الوزن مما يجعلها سهله الحمل كما يطلق
عليها بطانيات الفضاء او بطانيات الطوارئ
بعدما اثار فيروس ماربورج مخاوف العديد من
الدول خصوصا عقب اعلان غينيا الاستوائيه
وفاه ما لا يقل عن تسعه اشخاص بهذا
الفيروس عقدت منظمه الصحه العالميه
اجتماعا عاجلا حول الامر الصحه العالميه
جمعت خبراء الصحه من كل انحاء العالم
لمناقشه سبل تطوير اللقاحات او علاجات
لفيروس ماربورج الذي يقتل 90% من المصابين
به في ظل مخاوف وتحضيرات متزايده من ان
العالم قد يفاجئ بالمرض غير القابل للعلاج
افادت المنظمه بانها نشرت فرقا متقدمه في
المناطق المتضرره لتتبع المخالطين والعزل
وتقديم الرعايه الطبيه للاشخاص الذين تظهر
عليهم اعراض هذا المرض
صخره موسكو مما اسمته السخافات الامريكيه
بعد ورود تقارير تتحدث عن رصد اجسام
مجهوله قد تكون مركبات طائره من خارج كوكب
الارض السخريه الروسيه جاءت على لسان
الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زهاروبا التي قالت ان هذه التقارير مرتبطه
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه في 2024
مضيفه لوكاله سبوتنيك ان الموضوعات
المعاديه لروسيا وصلت لحد العبثيه في
واشنطن لذلك تبحث الحكومه عن فرص جديده
لمفاجاه وابهار السكان وتابعت زخاربا
ستكون هناك انتخابات قريبا بامريكا لذلك
سيكون هناك بوكيمون وستكون هناك ايضا
اطباق طائره على حد تعبيرها
وفي خبرنا الاخير كشف الامين العام للمجلس
الاعلى للاثار المصريه الدكتور مصطفى
وزيري تفاصيله واقعه نصب وايهام البعض
باكتشاف مقبره اثريه في محافظه بني سويف
وزير قال في تصريح للعربيه انه بعد معاينه
المكان المذكور تبين ان الرسومات كلها
حديثه لا يتجاوز عمرها العام كما ان
النقوش لا تمت بصله للحضاره المصريه
القديمه فيما كشفت مباحث شرطه الاثار ان
المقبره مزيفه بالكامل ولا علاقه لها
بالواقع الاثري على الاطلاق فالتماثيل
كلها مقلده ومصنوعه من البلاستيك وافاد
التقارير بان اجهزه الامن تكثف من جهود
البحث عن الجنات المسؤولين عن تشييد هذه
المقبره المزيفه